and who knew you could make beans
desserts why have we not been making
beans into desserts
[Music]
i love the moon and i love cake i like
how
how could this go wrong it sounds just
colorful and magical and happy
[Music]
if this tastes like half the effort that
looks like that went into making it it's
going to be amazing so beautiful look at
it it's an egg
i got the one with a big egg
is it going to be good it's not bad
well i actually really like it i didn't
know lotuses could be better
they're already so beautiful if it gets
too buttery around the tongue uh this
tea really washes it down quite nicely
yeah
okay i'm skeptical of the red beans well
i've had mochi with red bean and it is
pretty good also delicious
it's like super earthy less crumble to
deal with because there's no like center
of
cake pretty damn good sugar bean
[Music]
sounds really good it smells like meat
oh kind of bittery it's like a super
thick fig newton
yeah tastes like really old barbecue
sauce still
good my least favorite
it was some baller decaf it was
beautiful like i felt bad cutting into
them a snack fit for a queen i'm gonna
go with the red bean the lotus one was
the best one for sure i love the tea
with it i feel really cozy i just feel
like so calm i would love to bring this
to my family can we just start doing
this today how can we just get together
and have tea and cakes together i love
this
[Music]
if the queen of england visited east
asia
this is
the ceremony you'd want to bring her to
moon cake and tea she'd be like right in
her element